>> I WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT
BIDEN FOR GIVING US THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
WE COME FROM A COUNTRY THAT'S
REALLY POOR AND WE'RE LOOKING
FOR WORK.
>> Ainsley: ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSERS PRAISING THE
PRESIDENT'S BORDER POLICY AS FOX
NEWS CAMERAS CAPTURE THE EXTENT
OF THE CRISIS.
WATCH AS MIGRANTS CLIMB OVER
BARBED WIRE AND SHIPPING
CONTAINERS.
IT'S A THING THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT WITNESS DURING HIS SHORT
VISIT ON THE BORDER ON SUNDAY
BEFORE HEADING OVER TO MEXICO TO
ADDRESS IMMIGRATION WITH ITS
PRESIDENT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND RETIRED
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN
JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING, TOM.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, WHAT DID YOU
MAKE OF THAT?
THE PRESIDENT WENT TO THE PORT
OF ENTRY, HE MET WITH THE PEOPLE
SERVING THE MIGRANTS BUT HE
NEVER SAW ANY OF THE MIGRANTS.
AND THEN WE HAVE VIDEO OF THEM
OR PICTURES HAVE BEEN CLEANING
UP THE STREETS THE DAY BEFORE.
THEY WERE REALLY MESSY, FULL OF
TRASH.
THE NEXT DAY THEY WERE CLEAN.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS HOPING THE
PRESIDENT WOULD GO DOWN THERE
AND MAKE A MEANINGFUL TRIP.
BUT, YOU KNOW, JUST ANOTHER
POLITICAL STUNT.
IT WAS A PHOTO OP.
HE WENT DOWN THERE TO EMPTY
STREETS, EMPTY MIGRANT CENTERS.
WENT TO THE PART OF A BORDER
WHERE THERE IS A BORDER BARRIER.
OBVIOUSLY THE SECRET SERVICE
THOUGHT HE WAS SAFE WHERE THERE
WAS A BORDER BARRIER.
GET THAT AND UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THE BORDER.
WHAT HE DID IS DID A PHOTO OP.
I'M SURE HE IS GOING TO ANNOUNCE
HE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS NOTHING BUT A POLITICAL
STUNT.
HE DIDN'T GO DOWN THERE TO TALK
ABOUT HOW TO SECURE THE BORDER.
WHAT HE SHOULD HAVE DONE FROM
THE TIME HE LANDED IS APOLOGIZE
TO THE MEN AND WOMEN, THE HORSE
PATROL WHO HE SLANDERED FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE PODIUM BECAUSE HE
STILL HASN'T EVEN ANNOUNCED THAT
MEN WERE INNOCENT AND PUT THEM
BACK TORQUE WOMAN OF ACHIEVEMENT
HE SHOULD HAVE APOLOGIZED FIRST
SPEECH HE GAVE AS PRESIDENT
WHERE HE SAID THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE LAST ADMINISTRATION WATCH
CHILDREN STARVE TO DEATH ON THE
BANKS OF THE RIO GRANDE.
THIS IS TALKING ABOUT 20,000 MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE BORDER PATROL
WHO SAVED LIVES.
HE SHOULD HAVE APOLOGIZED FOR
SIGNING 90 EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT
ABOLISH THE MOST SECURE BORDER
THESE MEN AND WOMEN EVER HAD.
SHOULD HAVE SPENT A FEW MINUTES
AND WHY 14 SUICIDES BORDER
PATROL AGENTS IN ONE YEAR.
TRY UNDERSTAND THAT SEE IF
WASHINGTON COULD HELP WITH THIS.
I'M NOT SAYING HISTORIC BORDER
CRISIS CAUSED A SUICIDE.
BUT IT CERTAINLY WEIGHED ON
THESE MEN AND WOMEN, WHOEVER HAD
SOME SORT OF INTERNAL STRUGGLE.
HE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO STAND IN
THAT FRONT LINE AND DEFEND THIS
NATION.
INSTEAD HE WENT DOWN THERE AND
DISRESPECTED THEM.
AND CHOSE TO SEE WHAT THEY
DIDN'T -- WHAT THEY ARE NOT
DEALING WITH EVERY DAY.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Ainsley: MARSHA BLACKBURN IS
TOURING THE BORDER WITH GROUP OF
OTHER WOMEN SENATORS.
SHE SAID THIS FISCAL YEAR ALONE.
REMEMBER, IT STARTED IN OCTOBER.
THEY APPREHENDED 143 INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF CRIMES HERE IN THE
U.S.
WE HAVE A PICTURE OF THAT CHETY,
GUY DOWN THERE ON THE BORDER IS
ATTACKING THE MIGRANTS, USING
THIS MACHETE AND ROBBING THEM.
THEY ARE TRAFFICKING HUMANS,
THEY ARE TRAFFICKING FENTANYL,
THE BORDER CROSSINGS ARE
DANGEROUS NOT ONLY TO AMERICANS
BUT ALSO TO THE MIGRANTS.
>> WHEN YOU MAKE PROMISES YOU
CAN CROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY,
BE RELEASED INTO THE UNITED
STATES, WHEN YOU TELL ICE THEY
CAN'T ARREST YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE
SIMPLY HERE ILLEGALLY, THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
ARE GOING TO PUT THEMSELVES IN
THE HANDS OF CRIMINAL CARTELS TO
COME TO THE GREATEST NATION ON
EARTH.
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN OVER 1700
MIGRANTS DEAD ON U.S. SOIL.
IT WAS RECORD BY FAR, RIGHT?
ADD THAT TO OVER 100,000
AMERICANS DEAD FROM FENTANYL.
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES
ARE KILLING PEOPLE.
LET ME TELL YOU THIS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP, WHEN ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
WALLS DOWN 80%.
HOW MANY WOMEN WEREN'T BEING
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
HOW MANY MIGRANTS WERE WEREN'T
DYING.
HOW MANY POUNDS OF FENTANYL
WEREN'T GETTING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POLICIES SAVED
LIVES, PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
POLICIES ARE KILLING PEOPLE AT
RECORD NUMBERS.
>> Ainsley: I KNOW, WHEN THEY
HEAR DOWN IN MEXICO AND OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT THE BORDER IS
OPEN, MANY ARE SENDING
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE DOING THAT BEING
SO DESPERATE IN ORDER TO SAVE
THOSE LIVES, JUST DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, T